[Music]
hey tiff
yes this question's for you oh yes mommy
will you
get a room kiss kiss
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh that's a patreon video
all right so we're married you have a
wedding ring uh
you ever thought about maybe i
bullshitted my way through
buying the wedding ring and maybe you're
wearing a fake i told you to get a fake
diamond
actually i literally told you this
question does not apply to you then no i
told you i'm like
listen what are you are you saying girls
are cool with fake rings
tiff is cool with the fake ring i am
would you be cool with glass
oh
because i know there's like the the
synthetic diamond and then there's like
the the diamonds you
mine for right but then there's like
just bad quality
[ __ ] and then the one in a gumball
machine yeah i was telling you i'm like
get a lab grown
or if that's more expensive then just
get a cubix of clone i don't give a [ __ ]
any of these words they sound like
freaking transformers dude it does
decepticons right get it decided to get
optimus prime
um no but legit was telling you though
i'm like don't
don't give me a blood diamond right oh
true
that
is that what it is oh no because like
the ethical
because she doesn't want the blood i
know nothing about
sierra leone
the diamonds are forever song right yeah
what about that video have you seen the
music video for it i think so
so it was about like how like there's
children mining away in these
oh [ __ ] mines and and they're you know
basically they're
they mine until their bodies fall apart
and okay
these are the diamonds we're paying for
challenge oh that's [ __ ] up wait what
about jade because i want my future ones
there's chinese
kids for that one chinese kids yeah
these kids are doing it i don't know
yeah probably just kidding the laws are
different there yeah
but yeah so um aside from this fake
diamond would you be upset if it was
uh say just cheap crap oh [ __ ]
just kind of like all these years i
honest me personally yeah
you know what i'm like me for real uh
you know i spent thousands on it it was
actually hundreds
oh would you be upset i'd be
[Applause]
but the actual object thing i wouldn't
care
um interesting she's the keeper i love
he's the keeper
[ __ ] love you he has some confession
today
no that's that's [ __ ] real i went
through turn off the camera let's see
what she says
do the same answer anthony i went
through research
to get that shot stopping together for
the diamonds so you'll be like
i wanted a surprise that is interesting
tradition
in general it's but it's so risky it's
like right because she might not like it
she's like
right that's why with me i'm like
dropping a hint that i want my future
won't be jade but then again i don't
know who's gonna be pros
i don't know what's gonna happen i don't
know what my future holds but the point
is
what if it's like a big j buddha because
they're like you said jade
wait you have a big [ __ ] fat ass
happy jade that's kind of
gangster dude that's literally all heavy
and like you can't do because i am
buddhist yeah that would be sick he's
all smiling with his big ass ears and
[ __ ] doing the thumbs up
joe's gonna propose to me tonight if
biden wins
all right so uh i have a video here a
high school kid
decided to make tick tock so actually
his entire tick tock account
is based on his very premise he goes
around with a diamond tester
so it's like a little tool that you
stick to a diamond if it beeps at you
then it's a real diamond if it doesn't
beep
then it's fake [ __ ] this fucker's
stirring up some [ __ ]
this guy goes around school asking his
teachers to test their diamond rings
oh my god whether or not they're real or
fake that's so like
embarrassing that is weird but the
teachers are game for this you can also
see it under like a blue light
oh really oh can you feels like
imperfections i know nothing about
diamonds
i don't know if it tells you if it's all
right here we go here's the hairs you
don't get a little [ __ ] glass and you
go oh this is real
that's what you would think yeah so
here's a compilation of uh his videos
he wears his mask really high up
his eyes right here
isn't it pretty i think that's real
you sure can if it's not real my
husband's in trouble
[Music]
he looks fake he's gone viral for doing
this thing oh
seriously all right
that's real that's what happens when
it's real
why does he have a diamond checking yeah
how is this
what's popular with the kids right now
we like drama
us young kids like drama oh oh
um i don't know how to tell her real
right
this is fake oh
so you see this here this is my wedding
ring and this here is my anniversary
that's why they got them three stones
there that looks fake so you can test
them out that's hella fake yeah even
from the other one you could tell
because the light's not reflecting it
but that one's real oh [ __ ] i'm wrong
the wedding ring is gone
yeah that one yeah it's too [ __ ]
huge it's true what you mean you don't
think it's real
man that's after i have been married 20
years that's the anniversary i know
that's real
trying to get me like this back it's
going to be last one
how long have we been man over 20 years
he said you've been married 20 years
old for 20 years is that the same one
different different
teacher
can't you tell by the size of the
gigantic rock yeah
and she's there's no [ __ ] way that's
so sad you're not with a millionaire
that's a huge rock 20 years
honestly man i'd just be happy that it's
a nice ring am i [ __ ] weird
but okay i am pissed about the lying
part that part's not cool
she took off her wedding ring just now
see you later you said god bless you
i don't know how i feel about this
activity i don't like it i hate it i'm
like
what is this activity why is he doing
this there's so many ladies that got
fake rings what the [ __ ]
that's like wait how many did he go five
teachers and like three out of the five
teachers
that's well now i feel like i would
probably go check like well the first
that i know this
well i mean okay what if the guy was
fooled too true yeah yeah that's that's
definitely that's that's happening from
a pawn shop you could get it from a dumb
[ __ ] friend
who conned his ass oh i thought you
meant the guy with the checker what if
this was a fake checker no no no no like
okay so some guys could be like oh wait
my homie got the hook up
well like okay cool you know it's for a
discount okay cool
and then like they'll buy it right or
they're just
playing out cheap and shady and they'll
be like i don't want to spend that much
and then they go to a store and they get
it cheap
there's so many other like ways yeah
that's true because the guy might know
i mean your reaction i get it like they
probably feel like betrayed and
embarrassed so they'll like you're like
why the [ __ ] did you do that
right that's what i'm saying it's like
it could be that he was like what i
didn't know either let's both get him
you know
yeah yeah it's so sad
it makes me so sad the ones that were
fake yeah because then if i find out
that i was like
the guy just got gypped like there's no
way i could be upset
well and also because i feel like the
kids intention was to embarrass them and
i don't like that yeah
that's what i don't like using them as
entertainment do you think then the
teachers allowed this to happen for them
because they were down to because like
he i cut out the very beginning he
always asks the teachers for permission
to do this hey can i check your ring
yeah they're probably like [ __ ] yes
you're also kind of putting them on the
spot in front of other people right so
like why would you want to assume
insecurity when you've like maybe borne
the screen for like 20 years of your
life you know
right let me check this you're like i
mean but how many of your teachers
respected you you know what i mean as a
student
like i couldn't get away with [ __ ] like
that as well they'd be like go through
your [ __ ]
seat we're not even talking about this
go do your homework well yeah it's
always psychological because i think
they're so confident that
um it is real they're like yeah check it
i don't care check it but there's also
that one percent of them being curious
too
you know what i mean like if it's not
yeah i don't even yeah but if this was a
kid too
i would have been like the [ __ ] is that
machine right that's true like a
breathalyzer what is it yeah
it's interesting that they took it for
like the truth yeah because i wouldn't
immediately be like what the [ __ ]
i would have been like oh that machine's
broken and i go to a jeweler right after
i'll be like i need to check this ring
hey guys oh [ __ ] yeah yeah it's where
they're calling their husbands in front
of the kids
i'm super interested if about where it
was in their shoes i'd i'd
be fuming inside right i would keep my
composure and be like
oh that was funny yeah and then and then
when the kid's gone right [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] are you i'm coming for your [ __ ]
[ __ ] kill you
never show weakness i would be like huh
interesting ah yeah interesting
i i probably get huh it's interesting
no honestly i'd be questioning the
[ __ ] machine like so where'd you get
this
how much is it why do you have it what
about the the the lady who had
the two rings the anniversary ring so
one for sure beeped and it was like
super
yeah the only one and then the other one
was like she has one that is real
and then like you know 20 years later
maybe he just couldn't afford a real one
and like wanted to do something special
you know
i feel like there is pressure though
from guys who can't be honest
to make them happy and try to get
something dope
it's a pride thing i think for guys i
was confused okay so like so here's the
thing right like
like okay like not all guys can earn and
all guys
can give the world to women right so
they think that the ring represents
something big so to kind of like
they're just kind of making up her mind
saying like she's gonna be hella happy
when she gets this
right so then they'll buy something
but then they'll do it on a discount
because they can't afford the real [ __ ]
and then but they just want that
reaction of like oh my god you got me
this thing and i'm like yeah i did a
good job
but he did it like in a sneaky way yeah
because he couldn't [ __ ] afford it
right because that was the ugly way it
is but there's
it comes from i don't think it comes
from a bad place it comes from
a place because they want to make you
happy but they don't know how to do it
because they can't afford it so they try
to figure out a way to do it
like it's not so blessed but it's such a
unique
in in single moment in like a
relationship hope like ideally
ideally um it's so unique and and you
know
it represents something so to have like
secret or
be a lie even just a slight deviant
a white lie even just to be like
reminded that daily
such a weird thing to i'd rather just be
like look i can't afford it i would be
so guilty for 20 years
that's a conversation that needs to be
had instead of being sneaky
you are too reasonable you don't
understand liars
no but that's the thing how honest are
you two from the jump and that's the
thing it's like you know there's a lot
of
women who like need to get married and
pressure their um boyfriends to propose
even though maybe their boyfriend isn't
ready so it's like then they're so
scared to even say something like i
can't afford it right now like you know
you know what i mean so it's it's just
pressure on both sides
some guys just can't say i can't afford
it right because it it's just such a
pride [ __ ] yeah
and then also like like you said like
maybe she's not pressuring but maybe
she's so excited about the fact of
getting married
that he's like i want to make her happy
[ __ ] how am i going to make this all
work but also like
shouldn't you as the girlfriend know
what your boyfriend's financial status
is at least
you would think yeah but a lot of people
are [ __ ] dumb
yes you would you would be surprised man
yeah there's so many people out there
that don't even think about finances and
they're like let's get married let's buy
a house let's pop out kids
we can do it love will keep us together
and they probably don't talk about
finances they don't
yeah they just spend spend spend and it
just [ __ ] falls all over that's why
that's the number one reason why couples
get divorced
is over finances oh for sure number one
reason yeah that makes sense that means
the biggest
it's literally what makes the world go
around it's like the biggest burden way
too reasonably right yeah
yeah last question does the size of the
ring
matter so like you know if it's real but
you can't afford a big
real one do you spend the amount of
money that you have a lot of for buying
a ring for a smaller real one or do you
go
bigger to maybe impress her because at
first glance it's like
really impressive to buy a a fake big
ring
diamond i guess see i'm all about the no
pressure and like again it's like
spend time to get what you want more
what am i saying wait for the big
the real thing but just wait for it
right yeah
quality over quantity save all your over
quantity yeah
right like i'm in no rush you know it's
like if we can't afford it right now
yeah we because i'm going to go half on
it
essentially we'll split the bill at some
point i don't know what's going to
happen i don't know if i'm going to get
proposed to or if i'm going to do the
proposing who the [ __ ] knows
that's fun you know that's exciting
actually that is kind of exciting or
just happens at the exact same time
right
right now the jade ring is the one to go
send them notes with me and we'll go
shopping for you the jade i would love a
green situation yes i just only recently
realized i wanted to send them with me
yeah we don't know
[Music]
you